tout autre chose difficile de faire de
faire la transition on va donc s'en
passer on va peut-être ah non on va
prendre la direction de de l'Ukraine le
président ukrainien qui pardon presse
les Occidentaux d'agir vite de lui
fournir les armes et munitions promis
ces dernières semaines tout l'enjeu des
discussions de l'OTAN qui se poursuivent
aujourd'hui à Bruxelles on va écouter
hakkev notre correspondant Gulliver
crack sur le sujet
a beaucoup parlé des avions de chasse
lorsque ça récente tournait européenne
aujourd'hui je pense que les
ukrainiens et leurs alliés se
concentrent un peu plus sur ce qui peut
être livré dans les prochaines semaines
parce que les avions de chasse même si
un jour l'Ukraine les reçoit ce ne sera
pas tout de suite ce sera dans plusieurs
mois voire même plus d'un an et
maintenant l'Ukraine dit il est vraiment
urgent de fournir les armes qu'elle peut
utiliser tout de suite et notamment plus
d'armes dont elles dispose déjà et sur
lesquels c'est soldats ont déjà été
formés donc des chars T72 des chars un
peu plus anciens que les Ukrainiens
connaissent ils parlent de fournir plus
de chars de ce type notamment venant de
la Pologne et aussi de nouveaux systèmes
de défense anti-aérienne la France et
l'Italie ont promis de te fournir un
système qui est apparemment l'équivalent
du patriote est donc capable de abattre
intercepter des missiles balistiques de
type S300 S400 que la Russie utilise de
plus en plus et que les systèmes dont
l'Ukraine dispose actuellement ne
peuvent pas intercepter aujourd'hui le
ministre de la Défense au lycée reste du
coffre le ministre ukrainien a dit que
il focaliserait sur les tanks notamment
les chars et ce qui est nécessaire pour
à la fois contrer les attaques russes
qui sont en cours et préparé la
contre-offensif ukrainienne le ministre
de la Défense américain Lloyd Austin a
dit que il s'attend à ce que les
Ukrainiens lancent leur grande
contre-offensive au printemps